avant le tournage du prochain film
diffusé dans les cars jaunes bien des
étapes ont été nécessaires pour ces
étudiants en nageant médiation
informations et services afin de valider
leur diplôme
le projet pédagogique et d'expliquer
leur métier aux usagers à travers des
vidéos de 9,7 ktv avant d'arriver au
tournage d'un film bien des étapes ont
été nécessaires entre le délégataire du
conseil départemental et ses étudiants
en quatre cent huit heures cette
nouvelle promotion ambitionne de faire
passer des messages aux clients des cars
jaunes de jeunes visages qui apporte un
nouveau regard sur leur métier
mais le plus difficile reste de
s'adapter au format vidéo
le choix est donc de décrire chacun des
métiers à travers leur jeune expérience
et la formation qu'ils reçoivent
début du tournage à 4 heures du matin à
sainte anne avec abdou
lamiraux kupper la fin
du planning journalier ce planning dicko
chauffeur car il doit prendre en
fonction de son service et après
l'arrivée de chauffe et régionales quand
je lui indique son bus ont fait ensemble
le contrôle du véhicule quand il ya une
anomalie nouvelle j'ai conscience sur la
fiche stade pas que je remets en par la
suite a aussi révisé séparation des deux
sites
cette mari à sainte anne 3
une fois tous les quatre jeunes intégrés
au flux de la circulation
les accompagnateurs entre en action dans
toutes les gares et quand il s'agit de
résumer ce métier d' aide à la personne
devant la caméra
quelques prises ont été nécessaires
on était de 7,4 subi voilà qui passe non
pas ce soir ça c'est à projet bientôt
en fait on est en contrat d'avenir sur 3
ans dans l'entreprise
et pendant ce contrat d'avenir sur un an
on est justement formation formation ou
pour passer le diplôme on doit monter un
projet et notre notre projet justement
il consiste à faire un film
institutionnel pour informer les gens
sur notre métier sûr aussi seul réseau
car jaune sur comment ça se déroule
depuis hier on avait on avait un peu de
stress mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
une fois qu'on est sur le terrain on est
habitué à fait à ça on est au contact
des gens tous les jours on est tous les
fois sur le terrain donc c'est vrai que
là c'est c'est un peu non sens mieux le
stress les descendu donc ça se passe
bien bonne journée monsieur d'amour
voyage à vous mon week-end à quoi
sourire
ces emplois d'avenir financés par le
département sont essentiels pour le
bien-être des clients et la sécurité de
tous une vision où l'usagé est au centre
du service dan leur vision ça donne leur
manière aussi de se voir aujourd'hui
avec car jeunes et demain aussi avec art
jeunes parce que c'est la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui qui construira ce réseau
aujourd'hui et demain que son image
c'est mieux que par exemple si
on aurait fait lâche là le projet cela
rajoute par exemple ou écrit le journal
comme ça au moins on va essayer de faire
passer ça en boucle dans le dos les bus
cars jaunes pour que les gens
comprennent bien au l'importance de
notre métier de chaque personne à son
métier mécanicien à josip rotation les
accompagnateurs
nous sommes tous une équipe on fait tout
pour mettre en avant car dernières
prises avec la partie mécanique de ce
beau bébé de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros des nouvelles
attentions particulières qui font qu en
toute discrétion
le service est rendu au public en fin
contrat permet de faire connaître enfin
contre la maintenance et les transports
en commun je suis la plupart plupart du
monde s'est il ya des gens pour réparer
derrière nous commençons les gens sous
le dévolu au garage
regardez ces visages avec leur diplôme
en poche demain ils se roulent à fond